hey everyone i'm john coogan and welcome
to the second installment of my guide to
startup fundraising
last week i talked about how to decide
when to raise money and about some of
the trade-offs involved in that process
today i'm going to cover seven different
common sources of funding in the startup
world
and hopefully by the end of this video
you'll have an idea of which would be
best for you to target during your next
fundraise
as always the best way to raise money is
to build a great business
if your company is making its customers
happy growing the customer base
significantly every month
and has a giant pool of potential
customers all seven of these different
funding sources will be easily available
to you
the seven fundraising sources i want to
talk about are as follows
bootstrapping crowdfunding friends and
family
accelerators angels seed funds
and venture capital funds each one of
these has unique trade-offs and there's
no single best source of funding
it all depends on the stage of your
business and what your plan for the long
term is
let's start by talking about
bootstrapping obviously this isn't a
funding source in the traditional sense
but it's very important to talk about
anyway
at the earliest stages essentially all
startups are bootstrapped even if it's
only for an extremely short period of
time
and nearly all the investors we
discussed today will expect
some sort of progress to be made before
investing in some cases you might be
forced to bootstrap your company simply
because you can't find an investor who
wants to put money in
but that can sometimes be a blessing in
disguise early rounds are always the
most costly in terms of dilution
so by bootstrapping for at least a while
you might wind up owning a lot more of
your company in the long term
mailchimp famously bootstrapped their
way to becoming one of the largest email
service providers
and the company is still owned by the
founders they have focused on growing
off of revenues from their customers
and maintaining a profitable business
model instead of taking traditional
financing
many entrepreneurs struggle with the
idea of bootstrapping every day there
are companies raising millions of
dollars before they even launch
so how can you be expected to compete
the secret is usually to develop your
career to a point where you either have
enough money saved that you can support
yourself while you work on the new
business
or let your startup grow out of your
existing business directly
that's what the mailchimp founders did
they were running an ad agency focused
on email marketing that generated
positive cash flow
although the agency model wouldn't scale
very well it gave them the insight they
needed to build the software product
that would eventually become mailchimp
bootstrapping can be extremely difficult
both financially and mentally
because you have so much on the line if
things don't work out but it can be
motivating to have skin in the game and
know that there's only one path
forward crowdfunding is basically just a
pre-order campaign for a product that
doesn't exist yet
and it can be a great way to both fund
your business and validate the
underlying idea of what you're building
instead of convincing investors to buy
shares in your company
you go directly to the consumer and try
and convince them to give you money
months or sometimes even years in
advance to let you go build the product
crowdfunding works great for physical
products usually between a hundred and a
thousand dollars
the best example of crowdfunding i can
think of is oculus
for their first product the oculus rift
they set up a crowdfunding campaign on
kickstarter and raised over two million
dollars from nearly 10 000 backers
this crowdfunding campaign not only
validated that there was real demand out
there for vr headsets which had been
tried many times before
it also gave them cash in the bank to
start manufacturing oculus headsets
lots of electronic parts require you to
purchase in bulk and suppliers usually
want to be paid up front if you're a
young company
crowdfunding has the added advantage of
not diluting your ownership in the
business
backers who fund your campaign don't get
shares in your company they only get the
promise of a product
high profile crowdfunding campaigns can
also attract traditional investors
and that's exactly what happened with
oculus within a year of their
crowdfunding campaign they had raised 90
million dollars from silicon valley
venture capitalists
there is a separate category of
crowdfunding where you do give up shares
in your business
this is generally called equity
crowdfunding and it doesn't have very
many high-profile success stories
so i'm not going to go over in detail
equity crowdfunding basically lets
lots of small investors buy shares in
your company but it can create legal
headaches and has yet to be widely
adopted in silicon valley the next
common funding source is friends and
family
this is a contentious one because as
soon as someone says
go ask your rich uncle for a hundred
thousand dollars everyone says but i
don't have a rich uncle and that's
legitimate
not many people can ask their family for
money but it can be a source in more
ways than you think
jeff bezos raised the first 1 million
dollars to start amazon from friends and
family
and 250k of that came directly from his
parents now not many people are going to
be able to get a 250
000 check from their parents but trying
to raise money from your inner circle
can be a good check on your conviction
if you don't believe your idea is good
enough to risk your family's money
why would an investor trust you with
their money even if you don't have any
rich family members
there are other ways to have your
friends and family help your business
it's not uncommon for your former boss
to have enough money tucked away to take
a risk on an investment
you can also call in friends and family
to support you in other ways like
providing housing at reduced cost or
even letting you piggyback on their
wi-fi
if you do wind up raising from friends
and family be sure to treat it like a
real investment
show up to a meeting prepared and share
all the same information that you would
with a traditional investor
and also don't take advantage of them
and make your grandmother give you 10k
at an insane 10 million
evaluation even though she might not
know better accelerators
at the early stage an accelerator like y
combinator or techstars can be a great
source of funding
accelerators typically pair funding with
an educational component
you might receive 100k in funding but be
expected to attend sessions with
partners at the accelerator
and incorporate their feedback into your
plans over a few months dropbox is a
great example of an accelerator success
story
in 2007 drew houston applied to y
combinator with an early demo of the
file synchronization software that's now
used by millions
in the application drew had to
articulate what his plan was for the
company and how dropbox would be
different from the competition
the yc partners liked the pitch and gave
him funding to build the product
in 2018 dropbox went public and is now
worth 8 billion dollars
if you are going to do an accelerator
make sure it's run by people who have
actually built a business before
there's been an explosion of
accelerators over the past decade and
lots of
business people jumped into the arena
with very little real world
entrepreneurship experience it can be
dangerous to take specific
startup advice from people who haven't
themselves built a company before
so be careful angel investors are
essentially just rich people
and i don't mean that in a bad way they
invest their own money which does align
them with you
but it all depends on how much they
invest getting a ten thousand dollar
check from a billionaire probably won't
get you much of their time
but getting 10k from a founder who
hasn't fully exited a company yet
will probably mean that they'll try and
help you as much as possible many angel
investors were entrepreneurs themselves
and they just want to pay it forward and
help the next generation of
entrepreneurs succeed
others are trophy hunters looking for a
big company that they can add to their
twitter bio
and some just have family money and want
to be involved in startups because it's
trendy
these angels can still help you fill out
a cap table but be careful about taking
too much advice from them
when uber went public in 2019 their
angel round from 2010 got a ton of
attention
angels like jason calacanis made over
100 million dollars on an investment of
just 25k
since travis kalanick had already exited
a tech startup before founding uber he
was able to go directly to an angel
round and raise over a million dollars
pre-launch
angels are great for a few reasons
they're typically very founder-friendly
only helping when asked and not needing
board seats or other control provisions
they can usually make decisions quickly
and often have a strong network of other
investors that they can connect you to
to fill out your round
seed funds partners at seed funds are
also often recent founders
but they've raised outside money meaning
that they're accountable to other people
and might have a slightly longer process
for getting to a decision
typically they have employees and
offices along with a dedicated fund and
target investment size
first round capital is one of the most
high profile seed funds in silicon
valley
and their investment in ring serves as a
good example of this category of
investment
jamie simenoff the founder had built and
sold a small software company before
starting ring
and he had worked with the first round
team before so when he came to them in
2013 with the idea for a connected video
doorbell
he already had a relationship and was
able to close a 1 million seed round
seed funds don't invest in many
first-time entrepreneurs straight out of
the gate
which is why accelerators and angel
investors are such a popular source of
early funding
once you've made a bit of progress and
can prove that what you're building is
working
seed funds are a great way to raise
larger checks in the 250k to 1 million
range venture capital funds are the last
major source of startup funding and they
are by far the biggest
some vc firms like andrews and horowitz
and sequoia have billions of dollars
under management and have dozens of
people on staff
while it's possible to walk into a vc
firm with an idea and walk out with a
term sheet
it's much more common to raise a series
a b or c from a vc firm after raising a
seed round from smaller investors in
finding product market
fit occasionally a vc firm will have the
conviction to take a company
all the way from inception to
acquisition and that's just what sequoia
did with whatsapp
as early as 2010 sequoia partner jim
goetz had cultivated a relationship with
the founders of whatsapp
even though they weren't actively
raising money sequoia was able to invest
60 million dollars across
two rounds and ultimately make three
billion dollars from the investment when
facebook bought whatsapp in 2019 for 19
billion dollars
so if you know a partner at a vc firm it
might be worthwhile to keep them
informed on what you're working on
but don't expect to jump straight to
series a without some serious traction
and conviction from that partner
vc firms operate much differently than
other investors they have outside
investors themselves and large
partnerships that need to agree
on investment decisions in my next video
i'm going to go into detail about how to
meet investors and what a typical pitch
looks like
so please hit the subscribe button if
you're interested in seeing that video
when it goes live
and if you found a different way to fund
your business that i didn't mention here
please let me know in the comments at
the end of the day your job as a founder
is just to grow your business
so never lose sight of that it doesn't
matter if you have 10 of the most high
profile venture capital firms backing
you
or just some cash you've saved up in a
mattress if everyone loves what you're
building
you'll be successful with enough hard
work thanks for watching